we're talking Star Wars Battlefront -
more specifically the single-player
campaign Miguel you got to see the first
three missions that's correct
awesome so yeah as we know you play as
ID in the timeline takes place directly
after the Battle of Endor but oddly
enough and spoiler warning for those of
you who do not want to know about the
first three missions you're you actually
don't start on Endor you start in like a
Rebel Alliance starship you're captured
correct I mean I felt like the first
yeah this first chapter in the first
half of the second chapter really sort
of teased up the rest of the story gives
you context as to items motivations and
her being in this captured base sort of
just shows you just how much of an
experienced Special Forces
stormtrooper she is right because the
way she escapes from her confines she
uses this droid that she has yeah her
helmet right it's a seeker droid is she
the only one that has one of these
things i suspect that her her her two
mates on the inferno squad have them as
well okay there didn't see those in
action yeah it looked like it was called
ID 10 it's a secret roid I know I broke
down the trailer quite it's a kind of
excessively but like that's why I when I
was looking at the b-roll that EA
supplied us just a couple snippets but
yeah so not my surprise it is very much
like a gadget bot you know a guy's most
droids really already like r2d2 you know
you're hacking lock doors
you're even it looked like there's one
moment where like you could send it out
to like shock or kill yes so he could
shock them and I spent most of the time
controlling the droid by going through
vents right and eventually freeing item
the one thing that I really enjoyed
about the prologue is and I say this as
a as a fan of single-player shooters is
that the linearity of it I already knew
going into it was gonna be a nice
contrast to the much larger Maps because
the interesting thing that EA said when
presenting presenting the game before
our playthrough was
that it was gonna take it was gonna take
a lot of components from the multiplayer
I usually see that as a red flag because
you make it sound like it's reusing
assets we're using assets it's gonna be
like a flimsy you know story where they
just try to find a reason to do sort of
a tour of all the maps and the
multiplayer and this mate plane this
first chapter made me really optimistic
because I was just going through the
ship trying to sneak initially through
down these hallways but eventually I got
it got caught and it turned into a nice
first-person shooter experience cool and
you can swap between third and first
person that's correct yeah cool so it's
very much like the multiplayer so much
that this is still up in the air but
when I first heard about there being
star cards in the single-player you know
as we had this open beta frustration
with the heavy-handed nature of star
cards and luke rates you know everyone
was up in arms about it I I guess I
initially was frustrated but it just
makes sense in the respect that you know
the game has devoted so much of the star
cards to the mechanics right so you were
seeing I forgot the name of the shotgun
ability you have three abilities just
like you would in the multiplayer but
there were a lot of those cards you saw
for multiplayer in single-player correct
some of the ones that stood out to me
included the turret yeah I'm the ability
to scan your area and see where everyone
is which in a way it almost like kind of
nerf the experience but I believe that
was also in the pre in the first game in
the multiplayer yeah they had a lot of
those tokens or power-ups were on the
field
yeah those kind of transferred into
soccer but I mean the concept in the
context of unlocking them throughout the
progression I mean there wasn't a lot of
sort of like pop ups you know motivating
me to do certain challenges to increase
my chance of shaytans cars I just was
making progress okay
and I felt like by the time I got to the
last the third chapter I had a lot to
choose from
and makes me wonder like how buff I'm
gonna be by the end of
of the story and how that will translate
to using those same powers in the
multiplayer so were you able to we don't
have any footage of this but were you
able to like pause the game on the fly
and swap cards out or do any kind of
upgrading whether were there anything
like well I mean I was able to swap them
yes okay yeah I actually didn't have to
go to a console to manually swap them in
and out cool we have well regardless of
fact it's our cards open here a little
bit but they are in the single-player
campaign moving on yes so you you leave
in the mission one you you leave the
ship and X we won't spoil it but you
know obviously there's gonna be the
Battle of Endor so you're on the planet
you play as ID and you see the Death
Star blow up there's a lot of I guess
you can you speak on the narrative in
that respect right that seems kinda
interesting from the perspective of the
Empire I was I was very impressed on how
they framed and pasted this particular
chapter when you're an end or because
you start off playing his Island with
her trio they didn't the inferno squad
and you actually she and her team they
actually sound really optimistic it's
almost like a foregone conclusion that
they're gonna win yeah and your quote
your you're taking out a couple rebels
and then suddenly boom yeah everything
changes you really see how she is the
leader because she's like the of the
three she's the one who keeps her cool I
mean naturally I mean you'd want you'd
be pissed too
look alive agents we can grieve later
right now we need to move and and then
it shifts to this mop up slash escape
I love I've been seeing Star Wars of
this very rare context it reminds me you
know you know when you talk about like
world war two and how the Allies reached
Berlin it's not like everyone like drop
their guns maybe for like a few minutes
right so just seeing you know a Star
Wars narrative in that context of you
know it's not just you know Ewoks
celebrating and whatnot you are you're
playing the Empire as you're trying to
escape make sense of the situation and
the chaos and that that goes into the
space component and it was my first
chance of playing this the the space
battles in Balfron two and I was very
impressed with it yeah it's it's
actually interesting you bring up a
timeline because you think about Return
of the Jedi right like these events are
kind of coinciding the other which are
two Jedi it literally it's like des are
explodes ships leave and then it goes in
tonight and it's a big party but like
this kind of fits in as you said that as
a mop-up right it's like it's not
necessarily all done no one just like
calls it quits like so yeah you you
escape Endor after it blows off the
Death Star second one
yeah it looks for the cool you're flying
through a bunch of the Death Star
wreckage yeah right
yeah they're just they're served this
like this narrative wait to just flying
through the remnants of you know the one
thing you were counting on to destroy
the rebels and I actually cut myself a
lot of slack for dying once for hitting
some collision because there's a lot of
Death Star debris and getting a lot of
people dead bodies
you know taking out a couple chasing
some some x-wing fighters and just going
into some really awesome chases though I
want to put a past the studio's behind
this that the AI programmers might have
actually gotten the the rebels to
actually go to and go on specific paths
when you're engaged in a dogfight
because it was really easy to get into
these sort of dramatic expect phases
yeah yeah they're like they're like
getting you to like chase them as you're
sort of like you know coasting on the
top of like you know one of the ships
and yeah you know it's I would say yes
and no to that because yeah you said you
didn't play the multiplayer open beta
recently but that space battle over fond
or was the Starfighter assault map
because it was a Star Destroyer station
basically compare station I believe so
you're doing a lot it's basically the
same map but I would say that in that
open beta there you're right like the AI
programming of like ships and and like
blockade runners coming into frame like
there was some of that I could see more
heavy-handed in single-player like you
know you're asked to do these waypoints
but yeah like it's a count of that in
the multiplayer open beta like there is
always that spectacle like it's just a
really like the star fighting in Balfron
2 is looking to be like at least my
favorite thing it is like super
enjoyable
but going back to fajn door that just
happens to be the love of the the next
area mm-hmm
I believe it's a it's a new area I had a
nice chat with the the lead writer and
he he obviously did find it find it an
honor to actually have an opportunity to
actually help add to the the Lord and
the Canon that's cool yeah yeah so you
know I was chatting about this with
Oscar day us on our UK team who played
the game as well and I just chuckled the
fact that you're going from a place
called Endor and not going to fondle or
yeah well that's the Star Wars I mean
it's not Kashyyyk right who has the
balls to write that one but the other
than that EO speaking of Oscar days I
know that you guys kind of chatted on
the written side which is gonna be on
gamespot.com you check that out you guys
spoke on like the objectives throughout
the game being a little bland
but it was that in your opinion like the
detrimental bland in that it's just like
go here and defend you know like Corvis
is that is that your your kind of
capital ships like a Raider class ship
that I didn't has there's one point
where it looks like in space the engines
are down it's like defended
defend from the onslaught of x-wing is
coming in did you find that like he used
the term by the numbers and I could see
where he's coming from there were a lot
of familiar objectives but playing it it
didn't strike me as generic in I think
maybe because of the fact that my
takeaway was though it really just that
particular that this three chapter
playthrough just had a lot of variety
and someone who's played like one of my
one of the things I really disliked
about say like Halo games is the halo
campaign is the amount of like hit three
switches in this area right and it just
felt like like this artificial extending
of the game and I didn't did not feel
that so far everything everything had
like a rhyme and reason rudder like what
was going on cool yeah it looks great um
and that goes without saying like anyone
who's played the last game even or the
open beta
it is way for me as a starburst and it's
just waves of nostalgia like even the
secret droid you had um it seemed like
they were pulling sound effects from
like the Imperial probe droids that like
kind of like cooing noise like never
don't know man
hey Anna what do you think uh I didn't
is gonna side in the end you think she's
gonna join the rebellion or do you think
she's gonna stick with hops and be an
imperial based on the heavy handedness
of the trailer I think she's probably
going on the side of the road the Rebel
Alliance turned resistant resistance
that's right because this is a Segway or
hopefully to the new trilogy okay well
thanks so much Miguel you're welcome
thank you guys for watching see it